hello everyone here we have a pretty
insane bullet game between Magnus
Carlsen and GM Ark of 50 from leeches
jean-marc of 50 is actually a swiss
grandmaster although his identity design
unknown that that's why the hoodie guy
is here again and in honor of hoodie guy
i decided to do this video in a hoodie
now if he let two grandmasters play a
game and give him a lot of time they
will produce a pretty precise game but
if you make too strong grandmasters play
and give him like a minute they will
create positions that are completely
insane and such is the case in this game
this is a game from the secondly chess
titled arena magnus carlsen won the
first titled arena under the name Danny
the donkey here he is playing against
the doctor drunken Stein and it's quite
an insane game he won this titled arena
as well I don't know if he donated the
money from this arena as well from the
first arena he donated the $500 he won
to the next tournament so I don't have
information if he took the prize or
donated it to the third titled arena
unli chess but regardless it's quite an
insane game and if anyone has any idea
on the identity of GM ARCA 50 the Swiss
Grandmaster do sure and I will put it in
the description below so let's see this
game Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens up with d4 and it seems your voice
has been heard I could be mistaken but I
think they were reverted the sound back
to the old pleasing sound of the piece
is moving so d4 we have Knight to f6 c3
and c5 here Knight to f3 and d5 cross in
place D captures on c5 we have Knight to
c6 and Carson decides to defend the c5
pawn by playing b4 we have E 5 and a 3
so Carlsen did push a lot of points here
on the queenside and this will this will
make him suffer a bit in the center and
here black probably should have gone for
something like Bishop to e7 or continue
developing he decided to push f4 and
this isn't a mistake but you don't want
to pull those pawns too far so Knight to
d4 by Carlson and
we have Bishop to g4 setting up a very
nice trap Bishop to g5 Mikaelson Knight
to e5 and here with a move like Queen to
a4 check forcing an exchange of Queens
the crosnes position would be perfectly
fine but here he plays h3 and this h3
move again raises the question is this a
terrible blunder or a very nice town
move but you'll see what I mean here
ARCA 50 plays Knight to d3 check and
here you have a problem with white you
can't capture the night as the point is
pinned you're gonna lose your queen and
d1 and if you play something like King
to d2 then white is simply just terrible
even with the best defense let's say
Knight captures on f2 attacking the
Queen and the rook you have to move the
Queen let's say Queen e1 now comes a
three and if let's say King captures you
could capture with the bishop but then
your unpinning the night so so it's hard
to say which is better so after King
captures you capture the rook and you
can't capture the bishop now because
Knight captures would be checked and
then black would pick up the bishop and
g5
so probably Bishop captures Queen care
first and now you capture but now you
know white is down the exchange and you
have a king on e3 so not a pleasant
position
so after this night the d3 check it took
a course in three seconds to decide for
his next move which is Queen captures on
d3 so he decided to give up a queen for
a night and the bishop on g4 arca of
course accepts this eg after some d3 and
we have h captures on g4 d captures any
two Bishop captures on e2 and h6 now
across and simply plays Knight to d2 and
this night the d2 isn't the best
continuation h6 was actually a blunder
because now Carlson has this Bishop to
b5 check the King doesn't really have
anywhere to go other than this eise Evan
move you can't block with the night
because the knight is pinned you don't
want to lose your queen
so after something like King to e7 you
have this rook to a to move threatening
the rook to e2 check because the King
doesn't have any squares available for
him so probably something like H capture
son g5
after rook checks now you have to block
with the night but now comes rock
captures on h8 and now it's actually
white
that's better here you're threatening f3
all of whites beasts are excellent night
will soon be developed this is this is a
better position for white but ok after
this h6 move course and plate night - D
- we have Bishop to e7 this pawn cannot
grab the bishop as it's pinned the rook
will hang so castles castles and I
believe it's the old castling sound so
very nice Bishop to e3 now the bishop
actually was under attack on g5 and
Knight to e4
we have captures captures and Knight to
f5 now Carson opens up the attack from
the rook to the Queen and also this
Knight is now on a very nice f5 Square
you're you're probably gonna be able to
kick it away by playing g6 but you know
you don't wanna weaken your King King
side too much
so King Queen to c7 getting the Queen
out of the way and Bishop to d4 now
attacking the g7 pawn and here you
probably don't want to actually even
defend this pawn but orchid decided to
play Bishop to g5 we have King - see -
and now f6 nullifying the influence of
this bishop on d4 but now comes the
Bishop to c4 and here we with a bishop
prepare and this beautiful night and f5
Carson definitely does have compensation
for the Queen this position is at least
equal if not better for white it's very
hard for black to find a way to break
through here of course he will break
through with a5 later but it's not all
that simple King to h8 and we have
Knight to d6 now improving the position
of his knight even further rook a to the
8th and now Knight captures on e4 we
have rook to e8 and now f3 and if you
look at the position now the c3 pawn is
guarding the bishop on d4 the f3 pawn is
guarding the knight on e4 which is on a
light square so the dark square bishop
can't really do anything about this this
is this is just this is just pleasant to
play for white so Queen to f4 we have
came to b3 getting the King to safety of
course on a light square
and a-five now ARCA wants to break open
on the queenside to start harassing that
King we have night to be six attacking
the rock on e 8r up to e7 and here 90 to
f7 check this checks the King focuses
the rook so you have to give up the
exchange here rook captures Bishop
captures and here we have a capture Sun
beat before a capture some before and
Queen to c7 now Bishop back to c4 Bishop
to g6 was also an idea as the bishop is
attacked from the Queen this would force
the King to stay and on the back rank
and there would be some terrible threats
on the back row back rank but the Queen
is very close to the white king you
wanna bring your Bishop back to help out
with the defense
so Bishop to c4 we have Queen to c6 and
now rook H 2 e1
rook to e8 and now b5 pushing those
pawns forward Queen to c7 and here we
have rook - ecigs Queen to a5 and now
comes King to c2 and Queen to a4 check
and now you don't really have the luxury
of playing King to d3 and then double up
because if you play came to d3 the rook
is hanging on d1 so we have to block
this with the bishop Bishop to b3 queen
capture some b5 and now rook to e1
doubling up on the e-file we have rook
to a3 and this rook to a3 isn't the best
move but it's nearly impossible to find
a good move here for black you probably
just have to wait and see what white
will do if you play something like I
mean you don't want to get your rook of
the back rank as the rook and the Queen
are now protecting ee8 so the double
rooks don't really pose a threat of rook
e8 but if you try anything like maybe
activating the Bishop Bishop to f4 you
get rook to b6 kicking the Queen and
after something like Queen to d7 you get
rook captures on f6 and so it's pretty
much over G captures Bishop captures
with check King has to move only square
and now checking the king and winning
the Queen Queen captures Bishop captures
and here would would a bishop pair
being up three points this is probably
winning for white
so after this rook to e1 rook to a3 was
played since it's very hard to find a
move here for black here Carson place
rook to e8 check we have King to h7 and
Bishop to e6 now threatening threatening
Bishop to f5 and this was the critical
moment of the game I mean there were a
lot of critical moments in this game but
the threat is pretty obvious Bishop f5
check and the rook to e7 checkmate and
here unfortunately for the Swiss
Grandmaster he played Bishop to g2 g 6
which allowed for a very quick ending
but what a move like Queen to 84
this checks the white king and leads to
a pretty forced variation and it's hard
to say who will be better in that
position King has to go to b2 and now
comes the Bishop to c1 check if you
capture with the rook then Queen
captures broken on e8 so King captures
and outcomes rook to e1 check King to
rook captures and now not capturing with
the king allowing Queen captures rook
but Bishop to f5 check g6 now Bishop
captures as you're gonna lose that
Bishop anyway King captures and now rook
captures anyone and here you have a
queen against a bishop and the rook and
white is up two points so it's hard to
say if any player can make actual
progress here it's probably white what
is the only one who can actually make
progress here but you know it's probably
a draw since the king is wide open the
Queen will be able to harass him all the
time but after Bishop to e6
King to g6 was played and now I'm sure
you all can see what happens
King to g6 doesn't really stop the
threat of Bishop f5 check here
constantly simply played Bishop to a5
check King to f7 was played and now rook
1 1 to e 7 and this is checkmate so a
very nice game and I mean you can see
how a couple of strong moves
compared with a bishop repair can result
in an excellent game even when facing a
queen
so hell let's let's just check out this
position one more time after this Knight
to b3 check this is the question how
many of you would play King to d2 and
how many of you would capture the night
with the Queen like I said it took us on
three seconds to decide to do this and
this is in fact the best move so yeah a
very nice game from the second elite
chess titled arena I do hope you enjoyed
it
Carson won this titled event as well
like I said as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I would like to
thank James Java for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it and you know could of -
chess calm for reverting the sound back
to the the pleasing one that one was
terrible you know I read your comments
if there was like you know who's who's
doing the scissoring who's I mean the
sound was just terrible there there are
no words for it so yeah that's it for
this game thank you for watching and I
will see you soon